we've talked a lot of times and you
always talk about your ranch you've got
this ranch and you do these guy things
on your ranch yeah and I always hear
about it and I think that's you know it
sounds amazing and then the last time I
think I was talking to you mentioned
that you've got a bulldozer on your
ranch what do you need a bulldozer for
for whatever you want it's it's the
greatest thing like let's say there's a
storm and a tree falls down it's
blocking the road yeah well you could go
out there the normal way with a chainsaw
it'd take you half a day cut it up and
move it out of the way or I bet I know
where you're going you hop in the
bulldozer put the air conditioner on put
in your favorite Bob Seger tape off you
go and crush that tree wait you do a lot
of repairing fixing like useful stuff
with the bulldozer right yeah yeah oh
just drive it around cause it's just so
awesome it's huge
its weight so Everett do you ever just
drive it around blasting music and
you're not performing any function with
the bulldozer but you're just like doing
its figure eights or something no you're
gonna do it tonight good
where is very slow donut yeah low down
yeah where is the rant I can't tell you
now is there ever a chance just look for
a bulldozer yeah that's it that's the
only branch with a bulldozer just trees
yeah no you you once sort of invited me
to the ranch but I thought that maybe
you were kidding would I really get to
go to the ranch I would love it would I
fit in at the rim absolutely if with the
fruit leather rollup jacket or what I
have to wear overalls or something you
could wear that yeah you don't look
happy about this I like it it's very
soft I don't sigh when I hugged you let
me rephrase that
yeah
yeah I noticed when I hug you your
jacket was of I thank you very much I
guess we'll do some editing now and now
imagine what would happen if I came to
the ranch seriously what would we do you
know Conan O'Brien shows up at the ranch
and I'm like hey Matt you know let's
hang what would we do we would most
likely frolic that's the last thing I
thought you would say what do you mean
we would what does that mean we would
frolic what does it mean when when when
you and I frolic have you never have you
never frolic with a grown man
I'm not sure that I have frolicking is
like skipping right but skipping is not
as macho right frolicking is like a more
macho version I get through this
right that was really enjoy that's nice
that's nice
that was one that made me think ranch
[Laughter]